I always think you can describe science
as involving a two-front war in theory
it should be a two-front war against
excessive dogmatism and excessive
skepticism so excessive dogmatism in the
17th 18th century context is like the
Catholic church or it's the sort of
decayed aristotelianism and you know a
scientist you know needs to think for
themselves and challenge the the
um the sort of ossified dogmas or
ossified metaphysics and just do an
experiment you think for yourself
um but then you also can't be a
scientist if you're too skeptical so if
I don't think you exist I think you're
just a simulation or yeah it's
everything's fake nothing's real I'm
just in a brain being
you know I'm just brain and about being
that's why we're not interviewing that's
that's not a good that's not a good
world for science either so you can't be
too too dogmatic you can't be too
skeptical yeah um and sort of probably a
healthy version of science Cuts against
both excess dogmatism and excess
skepticism but um my scoring is it's all
anti-skepticism at this point uh the
scientific establishment it's all
circling the wagons and we have a
climate change skeptic we haven't you
know you can't be skeptic of you know
you can't be a vaccine skeptic you can't
be a skeptic of of anything and so it's
all against skepticism which is of
course the exact opposite of you know
let's say a children's science book
would be the design right scientists
thinks for themselves and is is against
dogmatism
when you see the frustrations that
people have with these things you know
the sort of lack of trust in these
things you know is the government
working to silence you on Twitter or how
is Google manipulating the search
results or all of these things do you
also see those as inevitable problem
problems that were going to happen as
these things with these things the
reason I ask is I heard you give a talk
at Madcon you gave the keynote speech
last year and one of the things you said
was that nobody represents the
individual at these big conferences and
I sort of think that's the same problem
that we have with tech nobody represents
the individual anymore we just have
these giant corporations that or these
giant tech companies that make decisions
you cannot get somebody on the phone you
can't you can't actually communicate as
yourself you there is you know there's a
business version of it something like
that yeah there probably are
all kinds of ways they have biases in
that direction you know there's uh
there's always uh Noam Chomsky the
Communist MIT Professor I always like to
quote him on this where he says that you
know the Republicans are the parties the
party of business and but the Democrats
discriminate the Democrats are the party
of big business and um and and there's
sort of like a central left I'm quoting
a Communists
entirely wrong about things or you know
but um but there's sort of a central
left sensibility where
um you know uh basically
big businesses can be regulated they'll
follow all the rules small businesses
you know they often make a little bit
more money by being a gray area not
following the rules to the letter and um
and so there is probably just this
structural anti-small business bias
that's that's uh
you know political regulatory cultural
partisan that's very deep were you
shocked how obvious that became during
covet I mean where you know Target could
stay open for you know the Big Box store
but the mom and pop that was selling the
exact same thing next door got closed
that that shows the bias right there
right the system just kind of eliminated
a certain set of people uh yes I think I
mean I I think it was um yeah it was a I
mean a dramatic shift in terms of the
power of big relative small businesses
and uh probably I don't know I I think
in some ways covet surfaced all these
realities that had been there for a long
time
and yeah this was this is the
institutional Center left establishment
in this country you know it's it's good
with big business it's it's anti it's
very anti-small business how did you
fight some of that with your businesses
during covet and figuring out you know
were people going to work from home or
just all of the nonsense that everybody
dealt with did you try to give as much
power to your employees and say do what
you got to do or well you know most of
the because even now a lot of the people
still don't want to come back that's one
of the problems that yeah most most of
the tech companies were were pretty
um well positioned to adapt to to covet
where you know if you're if you're there
were sort of ways you could do the
remote work
um
you could walk remotely do things like
that uh and it seemingly didn't hurt the
business too much and then of course
there was there was a way where covet
shipped a lot to the Internet so sort of
a lot of the the tech companies in which
I'm involved you know got a got a big
temporary Boost from covid even though
you know maybe they maybe they actually
got you know more bloated Less
well-managed in the last two three years
and that's that's what I worry about
yeah so it was it was actually sort of a
windfall for them and then the question
is just did they did they really take
advantage of it or or did they get um
even more dysfunctional in various ways
do you think more people in the tech
world or maybe even in the political
world actually think like you to some
degree but because of the way we the
hive mind is or the globalist movement
or whatever it is they just sort of
always go to that but I think you know
if you privately sat down with these
people about what their real beliefs in
the individual are in capitalism and
these things uh directionally yes but I
I think it I always wonder if it
actually works if you can't say it so so
yes the surely almost the definition of
political correctness that it distorts
things and that there are all sorts of
people who are people are less
politically correct than they appear to
be because political correctness is
about appearances and then the reality
is always that people are going to think
it's a little bit crazy you know there
probably are a lot of parents who think
the schools went very crazy but um but
then if you feel like you can't talk
about it or articulate it
it's it's not going to be that
well-formed of you at all and so that's
and so I I think the political
correctness
is is real to the extent it just stops
people from from saying things you you
don't actually get to a very considered
non-politically correct opinion right
it's interesting because that also then
gets to the stagnation part that you're
talking about people can't talk about
what the actual issues are you then you
really don't have to wonder why we're so
stagnated and why we got 140 characters
instead of flying sure there's probably
some way all these things yeah all these
things are are linked but uh but
um yeah I I think
I think if we live in a society where
there are an awful lot of topics that
are somewhat off limits you know where
you know and if we think about science I
was let's let's think about sort of
um freedom speech or debate in in the
area of Science and I I always think you
can describe science as involving a
two-front war in theory it should be a
two-front war against excessive
dogmatism and excessive skepticism so
excessive dogmatism in the 17th 18th
century context it's like the Catholic
church or it's the sort of decayed
aristotelianism and you know a scientist
you know needs to think for themselves
and challenge the the
um the sort of ossified uh dogmas or
ossified metaphysics and just do an
experiment you think for yourself
um but then you also can't be a
scientist if you're too skeptical so if
I don't think you exist I think you're
just a simulation or yeah it's
everything's fake nothing's real I'm
just in a brain being
you know I'm just brain and about being
that's why we're not interviewing that's
that's not a good that's not a good
world for science either so you can't be
too too dogmatic you can't be too
skeptical yeah
um and sort of probably a healthy
version of science Cuts against both
excess dogmatism and excess skepticism
but um my scoring is it's all
anti-skepticism at this point uh the
scientific establishment it's all
circling the wagons and we have a
climate change skeptic we haven't you
know you can't be skeptic of you know
you can't be a vaccine skeptic you can't
be a skeptic of of anything and so it's
all against skepticism which is of
course the exact opposite of you know
let's say a children's science book
would be the design right scientists
thinks for themselves and is is against
dogmatism so what do we do what do we do
to break 80 anti-dog which is a 20
anti-septicism that's healthy science
we're in a world where it's 100
anti-septicism and that's a tell that
it's hyper dogmatic and that the
scientists you know the scientists can't
talk freely about the science and if you
have you know if you have if you have
dissenting views you better keep them to
yourself or your government funding will
get cut off and they're you know they're
all in the sort of government welfare or
something like that if you're looking
for a more unfiltered lens into the
World of Tomorrow check out our Tech
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a wide variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here and to get notified of
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification Bell